as part of the immersion into the video
games i like to play
i like to explore and blur the lines
between fiction and reality
and talk about the what ifs so in the
series i'd like to talk about the shd
tech
and come to the conclusion of whether i
think these skills are feasible in the
real world
or a completely fictional idea added to
the game
in this video we'll be exploring the
likelihood of combat drones
but also turrets because these are
essentially the same thing with one
really only being a more mobile version
of the other
so let's get into it
one of the most important tools for any
division agent is access to the
intelligent system analytic computer
or isaac this system automatically
tracks and records every division
agent's movement and actions
over time isaac is a highly advanced
artificial intelligence entity
available to all active division agents
equipped with an shd tech transceiver
one of the shd's most important
functions is to provide division agents
with timely identification of units
during field encounters
linked via smartwatch to the agent's
scantech contact lenses
isaac draws from the network databases
to generate a nearly flawless
color-coded friend or foe recognition
system this system displays the
affiliation and the current status of
the units
directly onto the agent's hud this links
numerous dedicated assets
directly controlled by the division like
drones and other unmanned combat
equipment
using isaac drones and turrets are able
to operate autonomously
targeting hostiles and protecting the
agents
drones have been around since the 90s
where they were used by the us military
for surveillance
it wasn't until after the events of 911
where the first weaponized drones were
deployed in the middle east
predator and reaper drones have since
been developed by the us
and have been used in thousands of
operations in afghanistan northern
pakistan
iraq somalia yemen libya and syria
as the technology advances and the cost
to produce continues to drop
even countries with smaller military
budgets have been able to develop in
this area
it has been estimated that 80 000
surveillance drones and almost 2 000
attack drones will be purchased around
the world
in the next 10 years however all of
these military drones are controlled by
human operators
who decide when and who the drone will
fire upon
so what is the likelihood of humans
being removed from the loop where
ai-powered drones
will select and lock onto targets with
no human oversight
lethal autonomous weapons don't exist
yet but the technology to replace the
human with an algorithm that makes the
decision of when to shoot
does experts in machine learning and
military technology
say it would be technologically
straightforward to build robots to make
decisions
about whom to target and kill without a
human in the loop and as facial
recognition
and decision-making algorithms become
more powerful it will only get easier
according to lead ai researchers
autonomous weapons
are technically easier than self-driving
cars
they go on to say that the technology
and design required would be relatively
easy to put together in less than a
couple of years the algorithm could have
a fixed list of people
it can target and fire only if it's
highly confident that it's identified
one of these targets
or it could be trained from combat
footage to predict whether a human would
tell it to fire
or it could be taught to fire on anyone
in a war zone holding something visually
identifiable as a gun
and not wearing the uniform of friendly
forces
these technologies are being prototyped
as we speak
in the past few years the state of ai
has taken huge steps forward
facial recognition has gotten vastly
more accurate as is object recognition
two skills that are essential for lethal
autonomous weapons
new techniques have enabled ai systems
to do things that would have been
impossible just a few years ago
in fact the us army is already
developing a swarm of autonomous ai
drones
to protect combat helicopters the swarm
is modeled after
social swarming insects like bees and
ants who protect their queen
a drone nest protects the queen
helicopter at all costs
the protective swarms tasks will range
from sophisticated electronic warfare
to acting as decoys for incoming
missiles and they'll carry out these
tasks
autonomously so if the technology
already exists
why isn't there weaponized autonomous
drones being used
over time nations have come together to
prohibit particularly gruesome or
terrifying weapons
by the mid 20th century international
conventions had banned biological
and chemical weapons along with the use
of blinding laser technology
in more recent years the united nations
decided to formally address the issue of
killer robots
elon musk has been particularly vocal on
the subject warning that artificial
intelligence
is our biggest existential threat and
potentially more dangerous than nukes
stephen hawking said in 2014 that the
development of full artificial
intelligence could spell the end of the
human race
at the international convention on
conventional weapons in geneva
the 123 participating nations voted to
form a group in 2017 of governmental
experts
to look at the lethal autonomous robots
that can select targets without human
control
which could lead to a ban the fear is
that this technology would make it
easier for countries to embark on wars
and undeclared shadow wars putting
non-combatants at greater risk
basically the risk would be transferred
from the combatants to the civilians
a key ethical principle of warfare has
been one of discrimination
requiring attackers to distinguish
between combatants and civilians
but guerrilla or insurgent warfare has
become increasingly common in the recent
decades
and combatants in such situations really
wear uniforms
making it harder to distinguish them
from civilians given the difficulties
that human soldiers face in this regard
it's easy to see the even greater risk
posed by robotic weapon systems
in theory a preference for controlled
machine violence
rather than unpredictable human violence
might seem reasonable
massacres taking place during war often
seem to be rooted in irrational emotion
the history of warfare offers many
examples of more carefully planned
massacres
and surely any robotics weapon system is
likely to be designed with some sort of
override feature which will be
controlled by human operators
subject to all of the human passions and
rationality
at this stage it's impossible to program
a robot with reactions to the infinite
array of situations that could arise in
the heat of conflict
at a time where we are constantly
speculating of the future of humanity's
position as the dominant force on the
planet
due to the developments in robotics and
artificial technology
it isn't surprising that there are
concerns around giving a robot the power
to take a life
yet at the same time we're still
building and developing towards such a
future
what was speculation only a few years
ago is now a reality
due to rapid advancements in technology
which doesn't appear to be slowing down
anytime soon so getting back to the
question at hand
are the turrets and drones used in the
division reality or completely fictional
from a component weapon technology and
even an artificial intelligence
perspective
yes the concept is completely feasible
in today's world
but from a societal and ethical point of
view we're unlikely to see
these autonomous human killing machines
becoming commonplace in the world
depending on how this group of
governmental experts define lethal
autonomous robots
we're likely to see them continue to
develop in directions of a more of a
support role where they wouldn't be the
ones making the decision on whether to
open fire or not
but like we've seen time and time again
there will likely be some grey areas in
this definition
where the military equipment
manufacturers are willing to push the
line
[Music]
plus let's face it it wouldn't be the
first time that a secret shadowy
organization
deemed to be above the law has gone out
of their way to produce technology and
weaponry that would otherwise be frowned
upon
or illegal in other sectors
i've been thinking about discussing this
for a year or two now but i wasn't sure
if this was what people wanted to watch
truth be told
i have a bunch of scripts that are put
together over the years but never
recorded and made them into videos
because although i was intrigued enough
to research and write about them
i wasn't sure if anyone else was
obviously there are certain things i
didn't address
like the fact that some of this tech
seems to have an unlimited stockpile of
ammo for example
but some things will really just come
down to game mechanics and quality of
life for the player
if you'd like to see more of these types
of videos where i speculate and attempt
to tighten the gap between the game
universe
and real life let me know in the
comments otherwise thank you very much
for watching and i'll catch in the next
one
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
uh